vor der ostküste der usa explodiert ein
chemietanker
der das muss schrecklich gewesen sein
ein junger offizier kämpft sich bis zur
brücke durch
mehr riskiert sein leben um möglichst
viele zu retten
der einzige fluchtweg führt durch eine
wolke giftiger dämpfe
kern schlimmer geht's fast nicht
für das rettungsteam ist das ein
hochriskante einsatz
es war wie im horrorfilm und für die
ermittler ein verzwickter fall
wie konnte das schiff explodieren
sabotage keine ahnung
[Musik]
der new yorker hafen versorgt große
teile der us-ostküste mit öl und
treibstoff an diesem abend wird der 175
meter lange chemietanker beim entladen
der dritte offizielle motto lang
arbeitete sie
bei marina umfasst 22
1587 bruttoregistertonnen und
transportiert flüssige chemikalien
deswegen verlaufen überall land der
rohre und leitungen
an bord sind 27 männer einige sind
gerade dabei
5900 tonnen mtb zu entladen ok scheint
vorsichtig
die kraftstoff zusatz ist hoch
entzündlich es ist höchste vorsicht
geboten
auf pump ist experte für chemie tucker
wenn man mit explosivem material
hantiert muss man ganz sicher sein dass
es in der nähe des schiffs keine funken
gibt da darf nirgendwo eine zündquelle
sein
langsam langsam
die transporte sind riskant aber
notwendig
chemikalien sind in der heutigen welt
sehr wichtig und ihr transport gehört
dazu gibt eine schraube sicherheit ist
das a und o das weiß auch lucio motto la
nummer acht als nächstes
als dritter offizier sorge ich dafür
dass die schläuche richtig festgezogen
werden undicht sind
achtet auf löcher jungs
noch eine schraube
auch die lenovo zuvor acht jahre lang
die käfer dies ist ein erster triples
offizier
ich war sehr stolz es war mein traum
offizier zu werden und ich hatte die
aussicht vielleicht eines tages kapitän
zu werden
das mtb ist end lagen
jetzt geht es weiter zum nächsten hafen
wo die restliche ladung gelöscht werden
soll ethanol
das schiff hat bereits 10.000 kilometer
von saudi arabien nach new york zurück
gelegt in sieben tagen soll es sein
endgültiges ziel erreichen den hafen von
houston in texas
ich hatte schicht auf der brücke
normalerweise nehme ich einige
korrekturen vor überprüfe die position
und kontrolliere die umgebung
offiziell captain jack bereit zur
tankreinigung machen
die mtb tanks müssen für die nächste
beladung vorbereitet werden das heißt es
müssen alle rückstände entfernt werden
das ist ein sehr strenger geruch aber
die meisten crewmitglieder sind daran
gewöhnt dass schließlich arbeiten sie
auf einen chemietanker
in den sechs riesigen mittel tanks
befinden sich mehr als zwölf millionen
liter ethanol
die 22 seitlichen außentanks sind leer
und müssen gereinigt werden das sind
eine menge tanks die fertig zu machen
dauert drei bis vier tage
in den leeren tanks war aber noch immer
hoch giftige gase
wer das und riesige dampf gefüllte
hohlräume
mario wie ton ist sicherheitsexperte
fahrt
[Musik]
sollte man lieber nicht einatmen die
sind alles andere als harmlos fertig
normalerweise werden die rückstände in
den tanks mit einer starken pumpe vom
deck aus ab gesorgt
und auch heute ist die haupt pumpe
ausgefallen der bootsmann muss mit einer
tragbaren pumpe in den tank hinabsteigen
sehr kurz mann trug ein atemschutzgerät
als er den tank reinigte
die rhone würde man da nicht überleben
das runter in der maske ist das leben
außerhalb ist der tod
beim herablassen der pumpe ist äußerste
vorsicht geboten
man bringt einen fremdkörper in einer
gefahrenzone
weitermacht wenn metall auf metall stößt
können funken entstehen und die umgebung
hier war hoch entzündlich
ok
[Musik]
es dauert mindestens einer stunde den
takt zu reinigen einer kleinen pumpe
sogar noch länger
verdammt die pumpe geht nicht
die pumpe war kaputt wir mussten sie
austauschen
[Musik]
eine neue pumpe muss besorgt werden die
männer nutzen die pause um abendbrot zu
essen
dominator malentes ist der chefkoch an
bord
riecht gut fantastisch
dominator spezial
wunderbar es gibt reis dazu die meisten
kannte ich gut weil ich schon als kadett
mit ihnen gearbeitet hatte noch ein
bisschen würz fleisch damit bitteschön
die meisten waren befreundet vor allem
benedicto cabrera und ich
es ist für dich eine diktatur war wie
ein bruder für mich er war sehr erfahren
und hatte mir viel beigebracht
nicht schlecht was
[Musik]
nach dem abendessen hat die llano
feierabend
für mich war es ein ganz normaler tag
ich glaubte nicht dass irgendetwas
passieren würde
einige seiner kollegen machen
überstunden
bitte nicht an deck einschalten
ich hörte mehrere explosionen an deck
loderten orangefarbene flammen
die explosionen waren so stark dass ich
dachte alle wären tot
die bauermänner brennt lichterloh jeden
moment könnte die restliche ladung
explodieren der dritte offizier luton
ottilie weiß nicht ob seine kollegen
noch am leben sind
die live-show auf die lichter waren aus
ich ging sofort zum achterdeck
überall war feuer
die rohre an deck waren zerdrückt
auch der seitliche rumpf beschädigt
dann sah ich den kapitän und fragte ihn
ob er den notruf abgesetzt hat
haben sie sos gefunkt
er war sehr blass und stand unter schock
er antwortete auch nicht
ich dachte wenn er den notruf nicht
absetzt er macht es dann schließlich war
der notruf unsere einzige hoffnung
also nahm ich das risiko auf mich und
ging auf die brücke
über lodern flammen azoty tarnow sich
zur brücke vor kämpft
das war kein normaler gang zur brücke
das schiff brannte explodierte und
drohte zu sinken
die überlebenden versuchen verzweifelt
von bord zu kommen
überall lag zersplittertes glas und die
instrumente waren verkuppelt
von harnik gewesen sagen explodiert das
schiff gleich was das jetzt
ich konnte den notruf nicht ganz durch
geben denn es brannte überall und war
wahnsinnig heiß
[Musik]
die küstenwache beantwortet den notruf
ihre position
wiewohl er antwortete nicht weil er auf
dem weg zum dach war um das nächste
problem zu lösen
auch die llano will die notrufe
aktivieren
er riskierte sein leben um das zu tun
was am wichtigsten war die notruf baake
ins wasser zu werfen damit die
rettungskräfte die unglücksstelle
lokalisieren konnten
er gab sein bestes um so viele menschen
wie möglich zu retten
die notruf barke wird aktiviert sobald
sie auf dem wasser auf schlägt
anschließend überträgt sie die
koordinaten an die küstenwache
ein helikopter crew macht sich auf den
weg doch sie wird mindestens eine stunde
brauchen
was man sagte uns dass ein tanker in
flammen steht ich so einen einsatz hat
man nicht alle tage
wir haben nur sehr selten
rettungseinsätze bei denen feuer eine
rolle spielt bisher eintreffen sind die
brände in der regel schon gelöscht
rettungsschirme dave kabarett bereitet
sich auf einen riskanten einsatz vor
das war mein großer auftritt ich musste
jetzt diese menschen retten das war
enorm viel druck
es ist ein flug ins ungewisse
wir hatten keine ahnung was uns erwartet
wie es dort aussieht riecht wie es sich
anfühlt
während die llano sich nach unten vor
kämpft breiten sich die flammen rasend
schnell aus
es war wie im film titanic
der bug sinkt und der hintere teil des
chefs kommt hoch
der kapitän und einige crew-mitglieder
sind bereits ins eisige wasser
gesprungen
drei männer klammern sich noch an die
reling ein ingenieur ein matrose und
dominator der schiffskoch
gerade wollen sie springen als auch die
llano sie abhängt
ich versuchte sie aufzuhalten es war
viel zu hoch um zu springen
er weiß dass man es im kalten wasser
nicht lange aushält
sie mussten mir vertrauen
er schlüpfte in die rolle des kapitäns
und sagte ihnen springt erst wenn das
schiff tiefer gesunken ist
nicht springen
noch einen moment länger an bord des
brennenden schiffes zu bleiben war ein
ziemlich kluger schachzug der von einem
kühlen kopf zeigt
ich wartete bis das schiff tiefer
gesunken war
die männer gewinnen wertvolle sekunden
um die rettungsinsel in dem kalten
wasser noch lebend zu erreichen
ich bin hierher war schon springt
hierher hierher
[Musik]
ich helfe dem zweiten ingenieurin die
rettungsinsel
gesprengt jetzt springt jetzt mach schon
springt
ihn rein
die
mit letzter kraft erreichen sie die
rettungsinsel
alle anderen die vorzeitig vom schiff
gesprungen sind treiben jetzt im
eiskalten verseuchten wasser
in sehr kaltem wasser wird man
handlungsunfähig den muskeln wird wärme
entzogen die reaktionen verlangsamen
sich und nach zehn bis 15 minuten kann
man sich nicht mehr bewegen
plötzlich stieß das boot gegen irgendwas
es waren zwei besatzungsmitglieder die
wir dann an bord zogen
wir hörten hilferufe konnten aber nichts
machen
mit rettungsinseln kommt man nicht voran
dafür sind sie nicht gemacht sie haben
ballast an bord
überall ist diese schweröl und millionen
liter ethanol
ich kann mir keine schlimmere situation
vorstellen
öl und ethanol dämpfer hängen schwer in
der luft und drohen die überlebenden
ohnmächtig zu machen
schließlich erreicht eine lockheed c 130
mit wärmebildkameras die unglücksstelle
die c-130 hatte eine infrarotkamera an
bord und konnte dadurch die wärme
signatur der überlebenden oder der im
wasser treibenden opfer erkennen
auf ihrem bildschirm sehen sie weiße
punkte auf einem dunklen kreis es sind
die überlebenden auf der rettungsinsel
ich habe sichtkontakt
sobald dann vom such in den rettungs
modus wechselt schießt das adrenalin ein
aber deswegen geht man zur küstenwache
um leben zu retten
als der hubschrauber ab sinkt nehmen die
retter die beissenden chemie dämpfe war
als wir zur unglücksstelle kam spürten
wir wie die dämpfe im hals kratzen
sieh dir das an
es roch nach reinigungs alkohol
unser größtes problem waren die dämpfe
die ins cockpit strömten ein
gefährlicher ort an dem man nicht sein
will
die überlebenden benötigen dringend
hilfe aber auch die retter begeben sich
in lebensgefahr
sind wir bereit dafür unser leben zu
riskieren
[Musik]
während die bauern am atlantik versinkt
kämpfen sechs männer verzweifelt gegen
die eisige kälte und die tödlichen
dämpfer die sich überall ausbreiten
[Musik]
wir versuchten uns gegenseitig warm zu
halten die beiden männer die wir aus dem
wasser gezogen hatten bewegten sich
schon nicht mehr
das rettungsteam der küstenwache ist vor
ort muss jedoch auf abstand bleiben
der hubschrauber erzeugt der hurrikan
artige winde unter uns und wir hatten
angst die rettungsinsel zum kentern zu
bringen
wir hörten den hubschrauber
und wir hofften dass die beiden noch am
leben waren
und zwar klar dass sie nicht mehr viel
zeit haben so wie die dinge lagen
mussten wir schnell etwas unternehmen
oder sie würden sterben
alle hoffnungen ruhen auf
rettungsschwimmer dave kabarett doch das
team zögert ihm grünes licht zu geben
ich weiß nicht 11 das sieht nicht gut
aus
die piloten wollten nicht dass ich
runter gehen wir spürten die wirkung der
dämpfer schon obwohl wir noch nicht mal
unten waren niemand wusste was passieren
würde wenn ich an
doch kabarett nimmt das risiko in kauf
lasst mich runter
er verspricht sich nicht vom
rettungsseil zu lösen
machten einen direkt einsatz das heißt
ich klinke mich nicht aus sondern bleibe
mit dem heli verbunden wenn ich durch
die chemikalien kann nämlich wieder
hochziehen wie mit einer hange doch der
einsatz birgt noch eine weitere gefahr
die dämpfe auf dem wasser könnten sich
entzünden und ein hubschrauber baut in
der luft statische elektrizität auf die
über das rettungsseil nach unten
griechen könnte
die elektrizität hätte sich durch mich
im wasser entladen können dann hätten
sich die chemikalien möglicherweise
entzündet und unseren hubschrauber und
die überlebenden crewmitglieder in die
luft gejagt
ich landete im wasser ohne einen funken
zu erzeugen es ist unfassbar wie viele
chemikalien darin waren als wäre man
schlagartig sturzbetrunken ich kann
nicht nah genug an die männer ran also
löste ich mich vom hubschrauber
er hat sich losgemacht dave hat sich los
gemacht
ich hatte wirklich angst um dave er
musste hunderte meter im eiskalten
wasser schwimmen und dabei dieses ganze
zeug einatmen es war ein wettlauf gegen
die zeit je länger ich im wasser war
desto schlechter waren meine chancen
us-küstenwache ich helfe euch drin war
alles voller öl
sind zu sechst okay ich bring euch hier
raus
sagte einer nach dem anderen bleibt
ruhig keine panik jeder kommt drauf in
den hubschrauber
alles okay ich bin bei euch
also raus mit euch bringen wir euch nach
hause
das wasser war eisig kite
einer nach dem anderen wird an bord
geholt einige männer sind in kritischem
zustand
bist ok ja
der sechste überlebende hatte kein weiß
mehr in den augen als er den mund
aufmachte kam ölrausch
wie im horrorfilm
nach 45 minuten im wasser verliert
kabarett die orientierung
alle oben waren wurde mir klar dass
meine situation alles andere als gut war
ich verlor die kontrolle über nicht das
war einfach zu viel
wird für mich sah so aus als wäre der
ist bewegungslos wir hatten aber keinen
weiteren rettungsschwimmer ich bekam
panik denn wir konnten ihn da nicht
rausholen
ich sah den haken vierfach und wusste
nicht wie ich mich da festmachen soll um
wieder hoch gezogen zu werden ihr
programm
[Musik]
er hätte einen schlag auf den hinterkopf
gebraucht um das seil zu erkennen
dann bekam ich den haken endlich zu
fassen ich war total erleichtert weil
ich wusste dass ich überlebe
alles gut
kabarettistin sicherheit aber noch ist
die gefahr nicht gebannt die luft im
cockpit war feucht und ölig
die giftigen dämpfe sind in den
hubschrauber gezogen und drohen die crew
auf dem weg ins krankenhaus außer
gefecht zu setzen
uns wurde sehr übel ich machte mir
sorgen um die piloten nicht um mich aber
wenn ein pilot ohnmächtig wird ist das
etwas ganz anderes
ich war froh dass die unglücksstelle nur
30 seemeilen vor der küste lag und nicht
100 noch eine stunde in diesen dämpfen
und ich weiß nicht was passiert wäre
schließlich landet der hubschrauber am
sonntag krankenhaus in norfolk
die küstenwache hat heute gegen 21 uhr
30 6 personen eingeliefert eine davon
befindet sich in kritischem 2 im ernsten
zustand den übrigen geht es gut sie
werden in den nächsten stunden behandelt
und dann entlassen
alle sechs überleben der kapitän und der
rest der besatzung sind tot es ist die
schlimmste schiffskatastrophe in der
region seit mehr als zwei jahrzehnten
21 menschen kamen bei dem unglück ums
leben
die meisten waren meine freunde
darunter auch benedicto cabrera
[Musik]
wir den anruf bekamen war es mittags
hier auf den philippinen wir konnten es
einfach nicht glauben meine mutter
weinte
wir können nicht
[Musik]
ich habe wahnsinniges glück gehabt ich
danke gott dass ich noch lebe
die us-küstenwache leitet eine
untersuchung ein um die ursache der
verheerenden explosion zu klären
leitender mit larry cox
die grundlage jeglicher ermittlungen
sind beweise ohne sie lassen sich fakten
nicht verifizieren und dafür treten wir
jeden stein um
auch chris o'neill gehört zum
ermittlerteam
wie kann so ein schiff explodieren oder
sabotage war jemand an bord
verantwortlich
keine ahnung wir wussten nur dass die
zeit drängt
und das schiff liegt auf dem meeresgrund
beweise zu sichern wird schwer sein
um 36 stunden nach dem untergang der bau
marina ermittelt die küstenwache auf
hochtouren
im letzten hafen des schiffes sichert
sie ein wichtiges beweisstück ein
überwachungsvideo
aufgenommen am morgen vor dem unglück
lagen videoaufnahmen vom letzten
terminal vor
sie zeigten die ankunft die abfahrt und
das an und abkoppeln des laufes
sie entladen 5900 tonnen mt
wir wollten wissen ob sich die besatzung
ungewöhnlich oder falsch verhalten hatte
denn das würde rückschlüsse auf die
kompetenz der crew zu lassen
waren leute die gearbeitet haben die am
leben waren und plötzlich sind sie
einfach nicht mehr da das lässt einen
nicht kalt
das videomaterial bestätigt dass die
besatzung der bau männer bis zum
verlassen des new yorker hafens
vorschriftsmäßig gearbeitet hat
die eigentliche geschichte beginnt erst
nach der abfahrt aus new york
die us marine steht geheime
informationen zur verfügung die helfen
licht ins dunkel zu bringen
die sensoren eines überwachungssystems
das im nordatlantik u-boote aufspüren
soll haben die letzten momente der baum
erinnert mitgeschnitten
die aufzeichnungen konnten den zeitpunkt
der ersten explosion auf die sekunde
genau benennen
18 58 10 uhr fünf notieren bitte wie
sich herausstellt gab es nicht nur eine
explosion sondern eine ganze serie
dann eine ganze reihe weiterer
explosionen
als die zweite da bitte 18 uhr sechs
notieren die tanks sind nacheinander
explodiert aber welcher zuerst die
überlebenden könnten licht ins dunkel
bringen wenn man sie reden ließ er
nichts ist wertvoller als ein augenzeuge
aber die reederei hatte den männern
einen maulkorb verpasst bekamen
keinerlei informationen
den damit dann bleibt nichts anderes
übrig als das fragt zu untersuchen ein
tauchroboter sinkt 75 meter tief bis zum
wrack ab und überträgt erste bilder
mir fiel sofort das ausmaß des schadens
auf gigantisch absolut gigantisch
mein gott sie dir das an
man konnte mit dem roboter direkt hinein
fahren
das ausmaß ist unglaublich
ein drittel des schiffs so aus als wäre
es bombardiert worden wie in einem film
aus dem zweiten weltkrieg in dem eine
mine explodiert und das schiff in stücke
reißt
die ermittler wollen herausfinden welche
tanks zuerst explodiert sind die roboter
aufnahmen deuten auf eine überraschende
antwort hin
die mittel tank sind noch intakt
die ethanol tanks in der mitte waren
nicht explodiert alle ethanol tanks bis
auf einen blicken gefüllt auf den
meeresgrund die ermittle richten ihre
aufmerksamkeit jetzt auf die leeren mtb
seiten tags
die seiten tanks an der backbord und
steuerbord seite waren komplett
verschwunden
damit steht fest es waren die mtb tax
denen die luft flogen
warum sollten leere tanks explodieren
allein vor kurzem entladener tank ist
wahrscheinlich gefährlicher als ein
voller tank weil er eine mischung aus
sauerstoff und verschiedenen flüchtigen
stoffen erteilt
in einem vollen tank ist nicht genug
sauerstoff für eine explosion ein
leerer tank wird dann zum problem wenn
er zehn prozent sauerstoff und 5 prozent
andere flüchtige substanzen enthält
wir sprechen vom explosions bereich wenn
man dort drin ist reicht ein einziger
funke
die tanks müssen lediglich eine
bestimmte menge sauerstoff enthalten um
explodieren zu können aber woher kam der
sauerstoff als die ermittler weitere
aufnahmen sichten machen sie eine
erstaunliche entdeckung
[Musik]
noch eins
nicht nur ein mtb tank ist offen sondern
alle 22
die abdeckungen der ladeluke fehlen aber
sie sind nicht etwa beschädigt oder
wurden weggesprengt
sie müssen schon vorher geöffnet gewesen
seien
und man fragt sich wie kann das sein
denn sie sollten nicht offen stehen
[Musik]
das sind das ergibt keinen sinn die
lücken dürfen nur dann offen stehen wenn
der tank ordnungsgemäß gereinigt und
belüftet wurde
es ist nicht normal 22 tanks schon nach
wenigen stunden fahrzeit zu öffnen denn
die reinigung der tanks hätte zu diesem
zeitpunkt noch gar nicht beendet sein
können
da wussten wir dass irgendetwas mit den
tanks nicht stimmte das entsprach nicht
dem üblichen prozedere doch was ist auf
der bauma china wirklich passiert die
überlebenden schweigen und der kapitän
ist tot die ermittler weiten ihre suche
aus und landen schließlich am anderen
ende der welt
anhand der transporter konnte ich
rekonstruieren wie die buhmänner vor dem
unglück aus vor allem im hinblick auf
die tankreinigung der baum arena war es
interessant sich die gegebenheiten auf
der boot transporter genauer anzusehen
gereinigt die tanks sind ungefährlich
ich wollte in die tanks hinein gehen um
mir ein bild ihres aufbaus und auch
ihrer größer zu machen
[Musik]
um eine sichere tankreinigung zu
gewährleisten verfügt das schiff über
ein sogenanntes in erdgas system
bei diesem system werden die tanks mit
erdgas gefüllt
durch die reaktionsträge nähert gase
kann sich das gemisch nicht entzünden
was eine gefahrlose reinigung ermöglicht
in so einem tank darf es nicht mal einen
winzigen kunden geben sind die tanks
gereinigt werden sie durch gelüftet und
können wieder betreten werden
watch sieht gut aus
die technik an bord war vollständig und
in gutem zustand unsere tests haben das
bestätigt nach der inspektion des
schwesterschiffes sind die ermittler
sicher dass man die tanks hätte reinigen
kann doch was ist schiefgelaufen
diese frage können nur die überlebenden
beantworten
wir sollten mit der crew reden
die überlebenden verweigern auf anraten
ihrer anwälte die aussage doch nach
monatelangem juristischem tauziehen
wollen sie nach hause
sie hatten ausreisepapiere in der
philippinischen botschaft beantragt die
botschaft sagte sie konnten erst nach
hause wenn sie mit der küstenwache
gesprochen haben das war der durchbruch
zum ersten mal seit der unglücksnacht
spricht nord ii leno mit den ermittlern
die crux chris o'neill
der dritte offizier war am stärksten in
die ereignisse involviert denn er hatte
dienst als das schiff new york verließ
ganz am anfang an
es war ein ganz normaler tag sei
ein sehr freundlicher mann er hat mich
zu keiner zeit unter druck gesetzt er
wollte nur wissen was wirklich passiert
war
wir waren unterwegs nach houston alles
lief normal wir hatten keinerlei
probleme
[Musik]
der captain befahl mir die abdeckungen
sämtlicher seiten tanks zu öffnen
ich wusste nicht was er sich dabei
gedacht hatte
der kracher
heute locken aller seiten tanks öffnen
wir kennen seine beweggründe nicht aber
klar ist dass er sich nicht an das
gängige prozedere gehalten hatte aus
irgendeinem grund musste das schnell
erledigt werden
alle überlebenden decker weiter
berichteten dass das mtb überall zu
riechen war
das war eine wichtige information sie
hatten kein erdgas ins system gepumpt
sie hatten die luken geöffnet sauerstoff
drang ein und die mischung näherte sich
allmählich dem explosions bereich und
schon war das problem dar
der bootsmann stieg in einen
kontaminierten tank den man niemals
hätte betreten dürfen ein absolut
unüblicher vorgang
als wir erfuhren dass sie in die tanks
gestiegen waren fragten wir uns ob ihre
ausrüstung vielleicht aus metallteilen
bestand gab es reibung mit anderen
metallteilen flogen funken wie
vorsichtig waren sie
die reinigungsaktion der offenkundig
sehr riskant doch auch nach der
zeugenbefragung wissen die ermittler
nicht wodurch die explosionen ausgelöst
wurden sie brauchen beweise oder müssen
den fall zu den akten legen
dann kommt ihnen kommissar zufall zu
hilfe die crew eines anderen schiffs hat
den hergang des unglücks gefilmt
das war ein paar sekunden nach der
explosion
[Musik]
das war schon sehr ungewöhnlich
einen zeugen zu haben der das schiff
beobachtete und berichten konnte welche
farbe die flammen hatten und wie sie
aussahen solche details bekommt man
normalerweise nicht
noch wichtiger ist eine beobachtung die
ein zeuge unmittelbar vor beginn der
videoaufnahme gemacht hat
sagte das feuer sei ausgebrochen
aber die mannschaft arbeitete im
laderaum acht dort hinten
die tankreinigung hat er hauptsächlich
im steuerbord tank nummer acht
stattgefunden das feuer brach aber auf
der backbordseite aus
daraus konnten wir schließen dass das
feuer vor der ersten explosion an deck
ausgebrochen war
ein entscheidender hinweis die ermittler
verwerfen ihre theorie dass die
tankreinigung zur explosion führte
vielleicht hatten sie mit der explosion
nichts zu tun genau
[Musik]
feststeht dass das feuer nicht in einem
der tanks ausbrach sondern an deck
das deck eines chemie tankers ist
ziemlich zugebaut da gibt es einige
stellen an denen sich dämpfe sammeln
können
normalerweise trägt der winkt die dämpfe
davon aber nicht an diesem tag
fast kein wind
es war ein ziemlich windstille abend
sehr ruhig da wurde nichts weggepustet
das lied alles da hängen
ohne wind der die dämpfer hätte
wegblasen können traut sich an deck ein
explosives gemisch zusammen
die baumängel wird zur tickenden
zeitbombe doch
die entscheidende frage bleibt
unbeantwortet
was war der auslöser
wir suchten und suchten wodurch wurde
die explosion ausgelöst was war die
zündquelle
die handy die ermittler der küstenwache
suchen nach dem auslöser der explosion
an bord der baum erinnert wochen
alles mögliche kam in frage wir durften
nichts ausschließen
die ermittler gingen den ablauf der
ereignisse abermals durch
zunächst befand der kapitän sämtliche
mtb tanks zu öffnen
verdammt dann fiel die tragbaren pumpe
aus nicht schlecht ja wirklich gut um 17
uhr ging die crew zum abendbrot während
sie aßen bildeten sich tödliche gaza an
deck
die gase strömten aus konnten sich
überall an deck ausbreiten und blieben
da hängen er brauchte nur noch einen
zündfunken die gruber sich der gefahr
bewusst traute sich aber nicht zu reden
juni zu einer guten
sicherheitsarchitektur zählt immer auch
ein funktionierendes team und zwar rund
um die uhr das ist das a und o
eine kultur in der es in ordnung ist
seine meinung zu sagen und auch mal
andere meinungen zu sein auf der
berliner gab es das nicht
die gase sammelten sich an deck und das
unglück nahm seinen lauf
er ist der explosion 18 05 wann war
sonnenuntergang 18 uhr 18 uhr nur fünf
minuten früher
angesichts des
explosionsortes dass es langsam dunkel
wurde gehen wir davon aus dass die crew
nach dem abendessen zurück an deck ging
dort wenn sie wahrscheinlich darum
gebeten haben dass das licht
eingeschaltet wird
bitte denkt beleuchtung einschalten
wir glauben dass beim einschalten des
lichts ein funke entstand der das feuer
ausgelöst hat
nach der entzündung kam es zu einer
fatalen kettenreaktion
das schiff geradeaus fährt werden die
flammen nach achtern getragen die dämpfe
entweichen aus den tanks feuer und
dämpfe treffen aufeinander und boom
eine minute später folgt die zweite
explosion die durch mehrere tanks ging
viele der männer an deck waren sofort
tot
doch ein crewmitglied bewahrte in den
flammen entfernung einen kühlen kopf
der dritte offizier verhielt sich
heldenhaft
es war nicht einfach bis zur brücke
vorzustoßen
aber er trotzte der hitze und setzte
einen notruf ab
[Musik]
wenn ich die stimme höre stellen sich
mir immer noch die nackenhaare auf
lotte nordiran wird für sein selbstloses
verhalten ausgezeichnet
die us küstenwache hat mich für
besonderen mut ausgezeichnet aber das
ist mir egal ich denke nur an die männer
die es nicht überlebt haben
auch die hubschrauber crew wird für
ihren mutigen einsatz geehrt
schließlich veröffentlicht die
küstenwache ihren abschlussbericht
wir als ermittler wollen zeigen wie sich
so ein unfall hätte verhindern lassen
wäre in erdgas in den tanks gewesen wäre
der unfall nicht passiert punkt
das unglück der baum arena hat
diesbezüglich zu strengeren regularien
geführt wenn es in unserem bericht eine
empfehlung gab die am wichtigsten war
dann diese
doch für 21 menschen kamen dieses
regelwerk zu spät
luciano ist nie wieder zur see gefahren
heute leitet er in der baufirma auf den
philippinen
es ist schlimm dass so viele menschen
sterben mussten
während die sicherheitsvorschriften
eingehalten worden wäre das alles nicht
passiert
die leute die auf solchen schiffen
arbeiten sind fleißig und mutig
alles was sie wollen ist ihren familien
ein besseres leben zu ermöglichen
[Musik]